bacillus anthrosis are gram positive for
endospore forming and strictly your
facultative anaerobic organisms
bacillus anthrosis is the cause of the
disease Anthrax and is clinically the
most important member of the genus
bacillus
bacillus anthra says is a potential
bioterrorism agent because it can be
easily grown in large quantities and is
resistant to destruction
now where in the microbial world does
bacillus entrances belong
now be anthraxis when stained with a
Gram stain appears to be a gram-positive
bacilli arranged in form of chains now
if we divide the Free Living bacteria we
have gram-positive bacteria and negative
bacteria now gram-positive bacteria can
be gram-positive cookie or gram-negative
bacilli or gum positive bacilli now
gram-positive bacilli can be coronary
bacteria bacillus clostridium listeria
propiony bacterium
lactobacillus or a reciprocs today our
discussion will be about bacillus and
under bacillus we have two important
species that is bacillus serious and
bacillus anthrussis today we will talk
about bacillus anthrussis now spread of
vascular synthesis
can occur from animals now it is an
enzymatic disease that means it is
endemic in animals and spread from one
animal to the other but sometimes from
the animals the coat of the animals from
the biological substances of the animals
the spores may get into the soil and
from the soil they can enter the human
body also the spores can also go back to
the animals and can continue the cycle
of enzonotic disease in animals apart
from that the air the spores present on
the hides or the Farms or in the body of
the animals can get inhaled by the human
beings and that can also cause disease
sometimes as a bioterrorism agent
bacillus analysis can be spread by
humans and that can contract the disease
features of bacillus anthracis now
Ambassador synthesis is a gram-positive
organism that is it stains dark purple
it is a bacilli that means a rod ship it
bacteria and it produces Anthrax Toxin
and it can produce endospores
now the capsule in the bacillus
anthrosis helps them to evade
phagocytosis apart from that it has
three important
elements known as the edema Factor
lethal factor and protective factor
which contribute to its pathogenicity
now bacillus anthrosis produces edema
factor which is a calm module
independent adenal cyclist which
increases the level of camp or cyclic
amp within the cell which leads to edema
it also produces lethal factor which
causes cellular necrosis and the
protective factor is called so because
it is used in production of vaccine
against anthrax
the anthrax disease has two types it can
be either a
pulmonary Anthrax can which affects the
lungs and it occurs due to inhalation of
the spores of the anthrax bacilli and it
occurs mostly in the people who sought
the wool of the animals and are involved
in the winter winter apparel producing
Industries and hence it is known as
your Wolf's orders disease the
complication is hemorrhagic
lymphadenitis now apart from that the
anthrax can infect your skin now
whenever you get a breach in the skin
through that breach the anthrax pores
are basil I can enter your body and can
lead to a localized disease 95 percent
cases are cutaneous Anthrax they are
localized and sometimes they can cause
septicemia and organ dysfunction the
typical lesion of cutaneous Anthrax
looks like this
now how we diagnose bacillus anthrosis
in clinical samples now diagnosis
involves culturing in blood dagger which
gives non-hemolytic colonies now smear
microscopic and all it can be done from
the culture plates and they reveal
gram-positive blonde basili in long
chains apart from that we can also go
for immunofluorocin studies which will
show Anthrax bacilli now treatment of
Anthrax includes
antibiotics now for cutaneous Anthrax we
use doxycycline ciprofloxacin or
erythromycin and inhalation Anthrax we
cause a rifampicine we use rifampacine
ciprofloxacin or Vancomycin
to get notes and flashcards you can
follow our page
on Instagram and Facebook known as
animated biology with Urban the link
will be in the description box below and
if you want to support our channel so
that we can continue to create high
quality educational content for free you
can contribute to us through our patreon
page or you can use the super thanks
icon to support the channel which is
present in the bottom right corner of
the video you can contribute using paytm
PayPal or UPI if you wish to connect
with arpan the links of connection will
be given in the description box below
and for medicine related content follow
the nerd medic on YouTube channel until
then bye bye see you in the next one